hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares now we're at room 100 in
endless mode we've seen one I believe
one new monster but I didn't even get a
good look at it so I have no idea what
it actually was and we have four more to
go plus the other monsters that were
part of Cara Mari hospital and I vaguely
remember someone saying that I actually
didn't see all of them because there was
another part of Cara Mary Hospital that
I didn't get to right it was a pretty
interesting DLC I mean I don't hi how
are you doing those a moderately tame
entrance for you so I don't know exactly
if I saw absolutely every part of it but
I believe you know considering the
original game we saw the actual very end
of the game which is goodness gracious
man calm down like we saw the actual end
of this game and that's new should I
worry about the breathing I mean I know
I should worry about all the sounds oh
this is an ominous hallway okay it's
fine yeah the way they change up things
like I believe that they changed it up
so that there's more randomly generated
stuff and they mix and match like the
textures cuz when they made endless mode
I'm pretty sure they would have put in
some randomness to it considering this
is just going to be non-stop
environments as far as the eye could see
which is fanciful and free and I don't
mind it either way but even so I have no
idea so I'll be back once we see
something new nope
oh god oh god oh what's that whoa is
that is okay have we show oh hi
Oh am I still moving am I still moving
for okay cuz we're done with it now hi
to-do list I don't need you right now
I faintly remember something like oh
yeah I definitely remember the blood
door
that's a nice blood door oh boy man why
do I put myself through this stuff why
do I keep coming back here oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no where am i oh god oh
god oh no I heard a craving mmm I heard
it creepy who I heard a creepy creepy oh
hi hi hi hi oh man
that make me sick oh god I hope I'm
going the right way I can't see is that
it oh god I can't see oh no oh I can't
where am i oh no I can't see I actually
honestly can't see hi door holy [ __ ] I'm
a lost oh man this is awful this awful
is awful oh Jesus awful okay thank you
can this be over please could I be done
with this just are we out of the nope
we're not out of it yet oh Jesus
I'm almost F 150 I'm almost to 150 I can
get to 150 our water is this what
happened here was always why is that
intentional what Oh
now that messes with my brain okay and
150 okay we made it bada-bing bada-boom
hello Audrey sexual dark day for all
right I'm tired of this place today
scary slime man attacked me sort of and
I ran away I ran way we okay so that was
an awfully difficult 50 levels there
because they really didn't make that
like nearly impossible to do like they
put extra long levels and then the windy
ones I could not tell where the hell I
was going if it didn't return to reality
I never would have been able to find my
way out
and I would have died so hopefully these
next 50 levels are gonna be a bit more
forgiving but I have a feeling they're
not gonna so hmm day four I wish I had
Wi-Fi here that remains the scariest
aspect of all this place house I can't
check my online profiles or post my
daily thoughts it is making me build up
tension oh no you don't have a place to
outlet all the inane [ __ ] like I do
basic so I'm pretty much dead now I
don't think I can on and I know the
world will miss me but don't worry well
world I am still pretty hardcore for
making it this long I suppose but it was
a frightful journey kind of that's
really self-aware and hilarious so
hilarious you can see how much I'm
laughing about it ha ha hee hoo hee OOP
day 7 while I'm at the end of my rope
sexual press-on anyway I've been eating
the last of the cheese curds and haven't
found any new food there's something
down the hallway I believe it's getting
closer oh why why is this has to happen
to me well your grandma or your grammar
improved your grandma improved too but
your grandma is much better I don't know
how that's happening maybe there's
cheese curds are going straight to your
brain oh okay that's a different guy
that's a the exploration video oh it's
slimy
lovely at least we know how to deal with
slimy so I think it's like one new
monster every 50 levels which is not too
terribly bad and I can manage through
her dad a day only go down we already
read that one okay so the next one will
be something new well that's a new sound
what is that what is that
what's the rumbly wumbly why would there
need to be rumbly one belize over here i
thought this was a rumbly and/or wombly
free zone sounds like a helicopter going
through my brain okay I guess we're fine
okay I guess we're fine okay we got
through slimey so quickly I don't think
anything else I had a chance to think
about what it was gonna do man and these
have been much easier much more short
levels in the last one which is very
kind of this game surprisingly kind of
this game okay so we made it to 200
shocking hey guys so they're weird
cardboard pop outs coming out everywhere
I guess whose was a theme writer some
sort I'll just keep going down there
done a bunch of choice all-in-all it's
not that bad
go team kill the other team get the
sphere okay okay
knows about much much about sports as I
do okay so we're gonna blast through the
next 50 levels and hopefully not die
what monster we're gonna get this time
okay we started up right Ivo whoa what
is that do we get that before whoa whoa
whoa I don't like that okay so far not
threatening whoo okay now it's quiet
okay that's an interesting choice yeah
that's out it hmm I don't like that oh I
don't like it I know something's gonna
happen [ __ ] off cup of coffee a piece of
[ __ ] okay let's find this one hi my GERD
its I'm scared oh it's not scared
oh it's I'm scared oh it's I'm scared
all over again ooh that was the face
from ice I'm scared
Whiteface whoa that was so I'm scared I
haven't seen that in years I haven't
seen that in years like holy [ __ ] hey go
away go away go away go away go away oh
go away oh my god I haven't even thought
about that I'm dying why am i dying what
am i why am i dying I guess I don't
don't know hmm
why am i dying why is there blood vines
hanging from the ceiling oh I don't like
this afternoon in Manila Nana Nana Nana
na in the new oh [ __ ] what are you huh I
got by him I got by him I got by him
somehow I don't know how but I got I am
if I don't get stuck on any of the walls
oh I need more sprint where's my ax
wait a minute wait I I've been stuck on
room 227 forever ah I've been stuck on
room 227 I didn't even notice that how
the [ __ ] what do i do what do i do what
do i do what do i do what do i do i how
could I not notice that what so it was
just a matter of persistence what is
this what is this who's this new
[ __ ]
where's his music let me say my name is
necessary
okay 228 so everybody everything is
decent at least food is almost gone
water - at least the foundation this
place seems to be holding and there is
much mold in the air so I don't have to
use my mask I still want to get out of
here soon
what the hell was that
man oh hi that was a time sink that's
what that was Wow
but yeah I'm scared holy [ __ ] hi that
was one of the earliest horror games I
ever played well readers I found a
greenhouse of garden area it was pretty
neat but it didn't help me much
I did find a cool sickle thing in a tree
I know they don't steal from places I
explore but I have this really uneasy
Viper in this place and I want something
to defend myself I'm sure you do man
those nuts God that brought me back to
because I thought about all the other
like horror games I play because I'm
scared started a lot of pixelated horror
games and I guess this one could be
considered a pixelated or game but
there's a very specific style that like
I'm scared started man hey everyone I
wish my cameras that battery left I
found some really cool areas of this
building some looked like a school of
some sorts or another look like it must
have been a house restaurant I found
some frozen meat there but I'm not sure
if I should attempt to eat it or not
yeah probably I mean what's the worst
that could happen
boy more changes no time for this I'm
almost at the end plus it's gonna stick
me at 2:49 for a long time
wait wait
this way it skipped right by 250 hahaha
what's so funny the fact that I got to
go to 300 now to get a checkpoint
son of a [ __ ] mm-hmm
ha ha ha ha ha ha what's gonna happen
what was that yeah I don't like this
something's gearing up for me is it
behind me
it's about hey hi what the hell are you
what is that it's a giant beaver okay
its eyes I don't I honestly don't know
what to say about that it's it's
literally a giant beaver okay
oh Jesus getting faster oh [ __ ]
shouldn't look behind it's getting
faster oh boy okay don't do that no no
no I am fast enough to get away from you
I wanna be I want to believe ya you
still back there okay got away from the
murderous giant beaver don't know why I
need was that more is he back is he
still there [ __ ] oh no is he
actually still there because that's
something that I need to worry about
okay okay guys I'm done with this place
as interesting as it may be I think I
actually might be in life-threatening
danger I can't imagine going on much
longer if net gone way too far down to
get back up now okay so why'd you keep
going down obviously there's not gonna
be exit if you go down this is gonna be
nonstop into the ground dummy
oh why I'm almost out I'm almost done I
hope so
if it doesn't give me a checkpoint that
I'm just Farber knocked oh that's that's
a deep rumble that's a deep bassy please
yes okay thank you
oh boy Wow bunny okay Abaddonn incarnate
well readers I think I'm near an exit I
found another mansion like area really
feel really tired so I'm gonna take a
break here okay so anyway I am also
gonna take a break here so thank you
everybody so much for watching I don't
know how many new ones still remain but
it's gonna be interesting to see them so
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
hey what are you going on oh it was
going up I dropped on a pillar oh it's
just like every mother but delicate
fragile version of our mother
damn burger whoa dude